طالب بالفرقه الاولى بكليه الطب البيطري
بيطلب من استاذه طالب غريب جعل منه رمز
للوفاه القصه
رساله تحمل طلب انساني مرسلها طالب
بالفرقه الاولى بكليه الطب لدكتور ماده
التشريح طلب منه فيها منح زميله نصف
درجاته في امتحان نصف الترم وده لان صديقه
بيمر بازمه نفسيه بسبب وفاه والده خليته
غير قادر على الحل في الامتحان
واضاف الطالب في رسالته ان ازمه زميله قد
تدفعه لايذاء نفسه وعلشان كده يرجو من
الدكتور الرافه بحاله وقبول الطلب
[موسيقى]
الرساله ارتاحت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
واغلب من تداولها تمنى ان ينعم في حياته
بمثل هذا الصديق اللي وصفه كثير من الناس
بانه رفيقه ضرب الحقيقي ورمز الوفاء
والاخلاص
[موسيقى]
وكذلك تم تداول رساله الرد المقدمه من
دكتور الماده للطالب واللي بداها بزميل
المستقبل العزيز صاحب الرساله
تاجيل الامتحان او الغاء وحسب الظروف وضح
له ان الصحه النفسيه للطلاب ومصلحتهم
اولويه دائما
[موسيقى]